ladies and gentlemen take your seats our
program is beginning now all right good
morning everyone my name is Dan Belcher
I'm joined by my colleague vos Paula and
David Hayes from pager Duty I hope you
enjoyed the keynote it's good know a
good session all right at the keynote we
announced Google stackdriver and that's
what this session is all about it's
about managing workloads across cloud
providers since this is the first day
that we announced Google stackdriver we
have a lot of ground to cover and so
what we'll do is first prove I'll
provide an overview of the stack driver
suite we'll do a demo with a particular
focus on the monitoring and logging
components there'll be a session this
afternoon focused on the diagnostics
components and that's a stack driver
trays stacked driver debug and stack
driver error reporting which we
announced yesterday then I'll hand it
off to David who will talk about how
stack driver and pager duty work
together and then finally boss will talk
about stack driver in the broader
context of Google cloud platform and how
you can use tools like bigquery and
cloud data Lab to extend the value of
your stack driver data okay so for
context one of the things that you know
we believe it's that driver is that
visibility shouldn't be so painful right
we started this journey focused on
monitoring in 2012 and at the time we
met with many many customers who are you
running applications that's
the cloud and broadly I could say that
they fell into one of two categories the
first category they'd say well you know
we really don't have the visibility that
we needed to our application we're
relying on some basic capabilities from
the cloud platform but frequently we're
surprised by performance issues or
outages or capacity issues right and so
that was one category of customer the
second category of customer would say
actually Dan we're all set we have great
visibility into our systems we have
actually two teams that built and
maintained monitoring and hogging
systems on our payroll right and those
are teams actually that you know that's
they're doing that instead of helping to
build our applications and so one thing
that we believe it's factura at Google
stackdriver is that visibility shouldn't
be so painful another thing that we
believe is that we should be providing
you with insights to do your job right
not just lots and lots of data all right
because data actually isn't that hard to
come by and monitoring and logging there
are many ways that you can get metrics
many ways to get traces logs lots of
tools available for data visualization
log analysis uptime monitoring
application performance management right
there's a lot of signals that you can
get related to performance in fact
alerting is just another signal how many
people have gotten more than 10 alerts
today for an application a hundred today
for an application yeah a few few and
when we talk about providing insight
what we're really thinking about is that
that silos of data don't really help
right and this is one actually that it's
important to us at Google right and it's
really difficult to organize this type
of data and make it useful for people
who are operating applications at scale
if the data is stuck in silos so part of
Google stackdriver is about bringing
that data together so that we can make
it more useful finally this may be a
controversial thing to say at the Google
cloud conference but I'm going to say it
this isn't about Google Cloud it's not
about AWS in fact
also sort of in love with metrics and
logs and alerts and that kind of thing
but it's not about metrics it's not
about logs it's not about alerts it's
about you right it's about the people
who are responsible for keeping
applications fast and available and
providing you with the tools that you
need to do your job right and the sort
of general theme that were focused on
with Google stack drivers making ops as
easy as possible right and our
definition of easiest can it be really
easy for you to find problems right
wherever they're occurring in your
application stack can we make it easy
for you to fix those problems get to
root cause can we help you answer the
very basic questions that you need to
ask of your data like do I have enough
capacity my users running into errors
when they're using my application right
and can we do all that without creating
a really complicated system that you
need to integrate and manage and
maintain and so that's what stackdriver
is all about at a high level as we
announced Google stackdriver today there
are five components to we did a brief
demo on stage in the keynote and will go
deeper into those two that's monitoring
think of that as alerts metrics logs and
so forth logging which is exactly as it
sounds a really scaleable logging
pipeline that can accept system logs
application logs request logs and so
forth and make those searchable and
available to you and then three
Diagnostics tools one debug so you can
debug issues with your code in
production cloud trace distributed
tracing for App Engine applications so
you can compare latency for example
between two releases and then error
reporting really exciting tool that we
announced just yesterday that will
automatically detect when there are a
lot of one new type of error occurring
in your application and notify you when
that happens so this is the stack driver
suite we'll go deeper into monitoring
and logging here just for contacts the
way that we're thinking that we think
about integrating so we think about your
application stack right so integrating
at the cloud platform layer
integrating at the system layer
integrating at the application layer
right and collecting lots of signals
right whether that's logs or metrics or
traces or errors and then exposing
features that make that data available
to you okay so we'll jump into the demo
and show you how this all comes together
so this is the Sacre homepage you may
have noticed in the keynote we started
with a dark theme then we jumped to a
light theme that's one of the advantages
of the monitoring interface you can
choose whether to use a dark theme or a
light theme I'll give you a quick tour
of the primary console here in the top
left you see uptime checks so this is
basically probes that you can configure
to tell Google servers to connect to
your internet accessible web endpoints
periodically and confirm that they're up
and available okay so this can connect
over HTTPS or HTTP or UDP think of it as
a way of confirming that your end users
can access your api's and load balancers
and front-ends and so forth okay next
below that we actually have a preview of
a new feature with that's related to our
integration with pager duty you can see
that thank David is on call right now in
pager duty and if I wanted to expect
that you can see actually who's on call
next in who's escalation and so forth
below that you see sort of add a glance
health so this is where we try to roll
up these signals into a very simple way
of knowing whether there are any issues
so here I see I have a few App Engine
modules and they're green right we know
there aren't any alerts related to them
I don't have to worry about them
likewise there's a notion of groups in
application so this is a really
fundamental concept and stackdriver
where you describe how you think about
your cloud environment ok so you can
define groups based on for example cloud
accounts so if you have GCP projects or
AWS accounts you could group those
together in your stack driver
application if you have micro services
you could define groups for your micro
services
now the important thing with these
groups is you can define them based on
for example naming conventions or tags
and here I could choose an AWS auto
scaling group and I'd have a stack
driver group that corresponds to that
alright so as new instances are added to
the group those instances are brought
together in stock driver and that
becomes really important when you want
to have dashboards and alerting policies
that represent sort of the architecture
of your application and the way that you
think okay and we'll explore that a
little bit more detail in a moment and
then in the top right hand corner of the
stack driver home page you see incidents
so this is where you would see if you
have any alerting policies that have
triggered and we'll show you how to
configure alerts in a moment and then
finally on the home page you have your
sort of add a glance view into the
health of your environment in terms of
key performance indicators so here the
application that I have I have an
elastic load balancer sending metrics
are ascending requests that's being
routed through an engine X proxy and
then traffic's being balanced across
clusters on GCP and AWS right and so
this might be the view that I want the
metrics that I want to be looking at
every time I open the application and
this is very configurable and then below
I see recent events or changes to my
application so this is where you can see
that I have some alerts and the demo
environment that triggered this morning
here's also where I would see when
people make changes bring new instances
online and so forth so that's sort of
the overview of the SPAC driver homepage
now I want to just go give you a little
bit of context in terms of how you get
set up first step in setting up stack
driver would be to basically associate
your GCP projects and AWS accounts to a
stack driver environment so here you see
that I have six or seven Google cloud
platform projects if I want to add a new
project all I have to do is click add I
can select the projects that I want to
add and click add projects
connecting an AWS probably u.s. account
instead of being one step is just two
steps so the first thing that you would
do is create a cross account identity
and access management role inside of
your Amazon console that grants
stackdriver
access to query the Amazon API on your
behalf ok and once that identity access
management role has been created then
all you do is paste the Amazon resource
name into this field and click Submit
and you'll be up and running ok now when
I say up and running what that means is
you'll have a bunch of dashboards and
visibility by default so you don't have
to go and set anything else up in about
two minutes you'll see for example in
inventory of all your instances whether
they're running on Google or Amazon in
one list and this list could contain
here I only have 116 instances it could
be a thousand and sixteen or ten
thousand and sixteen it doesn't really
matter and I could easily search and
filter across those instances so if I
want to look at my apache nodes i can do
that
that's one default view another one
might be if I'm using as I am in this
case Apache web server so here the
Apache web server metrics are actually
being collected by our monitoring agent
our monitoring agent is a package of
collect d collect e is an open source
monitoring daemon with the rich
community broad deployment I bet many of
you are already using it and collect he
also has plugins to monitor things like
Apache nginx
rabbitmq MongoDB elasticsearch Cassandra
right you can go down the list and
stackdriver really thinks that these are
sort of native services that many of our
customers will want to use and so what
we've done is created dashboards that
automatically show the relevant data
from those services once you've deployed
the monitoring agent and you could go
deeper from here so I can look at here I
have Apache metrics I could look at the
host level metrics zoom into a
particular time period and so forth
you'll see a similar view on the cloud
side so for example when I configured
that AWS connection I could see my
elastic load balancers on pre-configured
dashboards that are very rich and
designed to help support the workflows
that you use when you have issues so for
example here these are all of my elastic
load balancers here I want to look at
one and when I drilled a look at that
elastic load balancer its fronting a set
of nodes and so I can quickly gather key
metrics for the ELB like latency like
requests like response codes and so
forth but when I have an issue for
example that users are getting errors I
may want to try to isolate that to an
individual availability zone so I could
drill in and look at latency requests
response codes by availability zone ok
so here I can see for example 400 out of
errors and uswest to be right and
they're higher than the others in the
cluster another case I could actually go
behind the load balancer and look at the
individual hosts so I can have a cluster
of hundreds of machines and this would
give me a way to drill in and look at
the capacity and utilization of the
machines in the cluster ok so that's
sort of the native experience that you
would get with a service like elastic
load balancer and you'd see a very
similar model whether you use on AWS
whether you're using ELB or RDS or
dynamo DB or Kinesis and you could go
down the list of integrations that are
available all right I guess it's about
time that we talk about Google clouds so
here you'll see for example Pub
dashboard for pub/sub in this
environment I'm using pub/sub and again
out of the box we get rich dashboards
for pub/sub for App Engine for cloud
sequel right you could go down the list
of GCP services where I would have a
very similar experience ok and so this
is sort of how stackdriver integrates at
that cloud platform layer at that system
layer and some of these application
building blocks
but these are all pre-configured
dashboards out of the about you but I
like to create my own dashboards and put
them in the format that I want and so
here I can jump in to look at a
dashboard that I've configured and it
sort of brings together these metrics
whether they're on AWS or GCP whether
they're at the system level or the open
source sort of building blocks and here
I might want to actually look at a view
that shows a little bit more data and
maybe I want to add more metrics and and
a couple really important dimensions to
this are we don't stop at that open
source layer we can go higher into the
application stack so you can send custom
metrics that you define that might be
the starting point for looking at the
health of your environment right so in
my case I have a custom metric for job
completion time now this is strictly
from my application there isn't an agent
that you know understands it natively
and that's available for me to charge to
create alerts on and so forth and so I
can add it to my dashboard finally we
can also get visibility from our log
data right so we have we'll jump to the
logs a moment but we can look at log
metrics so these are metrics that I
define based on my log data so for
example if I specifically wanted to look
at 404 errors in my Apache logs I could
create a metric that has those flow into
the system and bring that together with
the other data so here I'll save that
metric and so one of the great things
that we talked about earlier is how this
data all comes together and we try to
make it as insightful as possible here
I'll preview a couple new features that
you'll have access to soon they're
available in alpha the first is giving
you insight into kind of course
statistics across all of my charts so
for example if I go to the three column
view
I can see at a glance what the maximum
and minimum values are for a given time
frame I can also expand this to look at
all of the legends where I could for
example chart the standard deviation
across a large set of data or the mean
across a large set of data so if you're
managing hundreds or thousands of
machines sometimes you don't want to
have a yarn ball of lines in your chart
you want to look at get kind of key
metrics across these large clusters
secondly in terms of providing insights
one of the things again that we're
working on that I want to give you a
preview of is the notion of Vital Signs
so as I talked about earlier where we
have all these different ways of
checking to see if something's healthy
what our customers have been asking us
for is kind of a scorecard view into the
health of their applications and so what
vital signs is all about is when you
describe how you think about your
application using the group concept that
we discussed before we'll be able to
present a standard set of sort of
dimensions of health of your application
and whether your application is actually
healthy along those dimensions we're
really excited about this innovation and
look forward to making it available soon
so that's most of the sort of monitoring
side of the system but when we talked
earlier we talked about how we want to
support really rich workflows right and
sometimes it's not just about the alerts
and the metrics you know when you find
out at 3 o'clock in the morning from an
alert that something goes wrong a lot of
times you want to drop dive into the
logs and so one of the things that we
think about a lot is how do we support
that troubleshooting workflow right so
you might get an alert and see that you
have a drop-off in your engine X
connections and you're kind of zoomed in
to of you when you're looking at those
connections well what people you know
when we only have the monitoring
interface with people who do this they'd
say how do I double click on that line
and look at the logs alright and that's
really what we're building toward and so
from here with a click I can click
you logs and this will dive you straight
into a filtered view of the nginx logs
for the specific resources in the chart
for that specific period of time all
right so you're not wading through reams
of data trying to correlate manually
across the different systems so we think
this is really cool
and as we mentioned in the keynote it's
really simple to go the other way so I
could search and filter on the logs and
then it could create a metric that feeds
the data back into my dashboards makes
it available for alerting and so forth
okay one other point here we've talked a
lot about alerting let's make sure you
understand how alerting works so from
this interface I could create an
alerting policy by going to alerting
we can also do it from the charts so
again if you're looking at that zoomed
in interface for a specific metric you
can click create a learning policy and
it'll take you directly to the
configuration for that metric here I'll
do a little bit more of a sophisticated
alert so first you could create basic
lurks right where I don't know if I want
to look across my GCE instances in my
Apache Oh
Apache cluster on GCP and notify me if
any member of the cluster has CPU
utilization above a certain level right
this is a very low utilization cluster
as you can see you know we could do that
right but the stackdriver system because
of this notion of alerts can give you
can use it to have more sophisticated
alerts so for example on that cluster if
you're running many VMs you don't really
care often about a single machine having
an issue right I certainly don't what I
care about is the aggregate across the
cluster so here for that GCP cluster
what I might want to do is alert on
whether CPU again or let's say apache
requests
the total number of requests in the
cluster fall below to the cluster fall
below a certain level alright so here I
could say you know it's a bad thing if
they fall below 160 and then this alert
would go off pretty quickly so the
alerting feature set is very powerful
you're able to sort of express alerting
policies in a way that ideally keep us
from waking you up at 3 o'clock in the
morning when there's not an issue but
ensure that we do wake you up at 3
o'clock in the morning if there is an
issue right and there are many ways that
we can wake you up at 3 o'clock in the
morning the first one is you know right
of course I could generate lots of email
many of you just told to me you probably
get a lot of emails on alerts we could
do that too you could also use
stackdriver to get SMS messages I
suspect you get SMS messages related to
alerts pretty frequently you can get we
can drop messages into campfire or
HipChat
or if you have a web hook you know an
internal application that we can post
JSON to over a web hook the application
can do that
but perhaps one of our most powerful
integrations and most widely used
integrations is the one with pager duty
right and so to talk to us talk to us
more about that I'd like to welcome
David to the stage all right thank you
Dan
obviously pager Duty is super excited to
be partnering with Google and
stackdriver but I'm especially excited
because I get to show you a lot of great
new features with our integration so our
relationship with stackdriver has
extended back for many years but today
we're on route we're unveiling a bucket
of great new functionality but first
what is pager duty what we saw need a
many problem relationship sorry between
your monitoring tools and your people so
you manage a sophisticated
infrastructure and you monitor that with
hopefully stackdriver it's a great tool
but you may also be using Splunk for log
management you may sometimes find out
about things via tickets you may be
migrating off a legacy tool you may have
some custom tools that you've you've
implemented for some edge cases that are
unique to your business and what we do
is we roll those up into services
because at the end of the day
or when something goes wrong you don't
care what tool got to at first you care
what service is broken and then instead
of mapping those services directly to
people we map them to the teams so you
were able to manage your schedule so you
know who's on call for a particular
service maybe I'm on call now you're on
call next week we have a third person
who's on call the week after that and
then we escalate between those so if I
don't pick up my alert within let's say
ten minutes it's gonna escalate to
somebody else and then possibly do a
third layer to make sure that it's
resolved within the SLA and then finally
the the bit that Dan alluded to we do
wake you up at 3:00 a.m. that's not our
goal in life it's to help you fix
problems as soon as possible but we are
very noisy well phone you will push them
messages too you will SMS you will email
you so what's exciting and what's new as
of today is the stock driver page of
duty integration has three great new
check boxes it's bi-directional so
whichever your single source of truth is
whatever screen you're looking at
whether it's stack driver or whether
it's page duty you're gonna see exactly
the same information so if your team
uses stack driver my team uses page or
duty we're all we're gonna be on the
exact same page as to what's broken what
the state of the world is and who's on
it we show the on call schedules now in
stackdriver again so at a glance you're
able to see who's responsible for fixing
anything should it happen and my
favorite feature we now embed live
charts from stackdriver
in your page of duty alerts so you'll be
able to dive in the second we notify you
and start resolving the issue all right
let's see some of these things in action
as Dan pointed out earlier we have the
the schedule displayed as a dashboard
widget in stackdriver it basically just
works and I'm actually you don't mind
I'm gonna go off script and I'm gonna
thank your design team because that is a
beautiful looking widget it really
captures a concise view of understanding
who's on call and when that's going to
change
we also stack driver has the concept of
incidents and obviously page duty does
as well and now the two the two will
stay in sync so we have here stock
driver incident referring to something
broken and then in pager duty
we have the same incident and as you can
see it links right back to the stack
driver incident so that whatever your
next steps in resolution
you're able to get there quickly and
effectively and like I said my favorite
feature we show the live stackdriver
chart so this is this is interactive I
can zoom in to find out exactly when and
how something went wrong you can tell
just by looking at this that I'm faking
my demo that we basically took a process
and we killed it and we were alerting on
it but the big thing you get from this
is as soon as you get your alert you're
able to tell what kind of situation
you're dealing with before you've even
logged in to any other tools before
you've jumped on to whatever your
resolution path is because the graph
tells you an awful lot so here's where
we're gonna do the technically
sophisticated part of my presentation
and I'm gonna gesticulate wildly because
there's very different kinds of graphs
so if you've got a threshold set here
and it's broken by what we technically
referred to as a chugga-chugga-chugga
gradual thing you've got a very
different problem than if you've got a
metric that's chugging along at one to
two percent of the threshold and then
shoots up dramatically similarly it's up
to the minute so if you let's say it
takes those ten those fifteen minutes
for you to get woken up and focus your
eyes on your phone you're now looking at
this seconds data as opposed to when the
incident was triggered so you might even
be looking at the resolution of the
incident might have evolved so perhaps
it's crested above the threshold and
it's trending down which is a good sign
or perhaps it went above the threshold
and it plummeted to zero which is a very
bad sign and you know you're going to be
dealing with a very different kind of
issue and naturally because we've been
working with stackdriver
for so long the configuration is super
easy you basically you just drop in your
authentication or if you get to it
before I have a chance to change it you
can drop in my authentication and you've
got a perfect you've got a smooth hand
off between stackdriver and pager duty
and speaking of smooth handoffs damn
thank you very much David we've been
really a great partner with pager duty
now for several years one of our most
important integrations and widely used
if you want to learn more about pager
duty they have a spot in the partner
zone so you could go there to ask ask
questions learn more integrations there
are many in the stack driver service
some of the newest and most exciting
ones are with our big data services and
so what I'd like to do is ask vas to
demonstrate how you can use Google
stackdriver with the big data services
in Google cloud thank you Dan
we worked really hard to make sure that
stackdriver delivers an awesome
experience right out of the box
hopefully we saw that in the keynote and
with Dan's demo today
and we're pretty confident that for 90%
of the use cases our customers will have
stackdriver is more than adequate but
what about the 10% of use cases when
stock driver isn't quite the answer to
your question
you know today other vendors offer
products where it's either their product
or nothing we've taken a very different
position we think stock travel is
totally awesome but if you would like to
get directly at the underlying data
we're gonna give you an ad hoc interface
that let you play directly with the data
of its stock driver out of the way and
I'm gonna give you two demonstrations
that show you how you can pull this off
the first is an integration with
bigquery as you heard in the keynote one
of the things bigquery is really awesome
for is dealing with petabyte scale data
with a simple sequel like interface now
where do you see petabyte scale data
where you need a sequel like interface
logs so I'm gonna show you in the first
demonstration how with just a mouse
click or two you can stream logs from
stock driver to bigquery and go into the
bigquery console and you have a query
playground at your fingertips see that
demo first so what I'm showing you here
is your logs view and you can see these
are actually logs coming from our Amazon
project so we are cross-platform now
let's say that the particular way that
we allow you to query logs is is not
quite what you want
you'll notice here this an exports
button so when you click on exports it
takes you this view where you can pick
the service you want so I'm picking my
Amazon ec2 service and if you already
have a bigquery instant setup you can
select it over here or you can create a
new one and right here from this menu
and stock-car will take care of all of
the creation for you so there's no
configuration of bigquery or any such
thing essentially two mouse clicks
select select you've got a big query
instance and now what happens is really
cool start Trevor will now automatically
stream your log data into bigquery
you don't need to do anything else you
can just go straight to the bigquery
query editor and here I have a query for
which I'm gonna look at my apache access
logs and if you're not familiar with the
bigquery query interface it's pretty
cool you can you can see a query the
table schema details preview and you can
just edit your custom query and just run
the query in this particular case I've
picked the camp query where I want to
count the number of HTTP 200 and 404
errors the stock driver logs viewer is
very good at searching for keywords in
the logs but it's not set up to count
the number of HTTP 204 for errors just
to show you an example I've taken in
this case and the query is pretty long
here and I'm also going to group the
search results by service and by region
so let's run that query and here are the
answers right it's grouped it by region
shows you how many to 200 and 404 errors
again here's a very simple demonstration
of the power of running on stack Trevor
on the Google cloud platform
this is cross-platform we took all the
logs that are already in stack driver
and we piped it into bigquery and give
you an ad hoc query interface to play
that
all right hmm so on to the second
demonstration what about your time
series metric data that's another
valuable source of data that stackdriver
provides I think the super cool awesome
interface for but maybe there are
situations when you want to slice and
dice the data and visualize it in a way
that is not available on the stack
Trevor dashboard and perhaps you want to
run some third-party tools or open
source tools on the time series metric
data how would you do that well welcome
to data lab it was briefly mentioned at
the keynote along with the bigquery
presentation so let me just remind you
Google Cloud Data Lab was a product we
announced last year it's in beta and it
is based on Jupiter formerly called
ipython and it is baked into the Google
cloud platform so you could start up a
data lab instance on any GCP project and
it gives you an interactive Python
environment to work with and you can
just directly program away in Python and
as you saw in the keynote data lab
already supports large data services on
GCP such as bigquery cloud sequel etc
and what we're going to show you now is
we've also added support to tap into
your time series metric data inside
stackdriver
and I think it's super cool let's take a
look at that so here we go
what you're looking at here is a data
Lab instance and I'm pointing to this
demo project on which Dan showed all of
his graphs earlier and this is an eye
Python notebook so the the and
everything you're seeing here consists
of Python cells that are all executable
and when you execute a Python cell it's
results are shown immediately beneath it
and it's completely interactive as I'm
going to show you in just a second but
the other really neat thing about a
notebook is it it is you can treat it
like a dark like a document
and this notebook can be shared among
other developers within your team so
it's awesome for running what have
experiments with data hey you know
here's a query I ran out of time series
metric look at what it found and just
share it with your other developers it's
super awesome for those kinds of tasks
so let's first go through a few candids
ampuls I've got in here just to explain
how this works and get a feel for it so
what this shows is at the very top here
I've got my import so from stock driver
important monitoring as GCM so this
variable GCM that that object GCM
contains all of the utilities that we've
built into data lab what's happening
here is I'm running a query this is just
querying the time series metric data
inside stackdriver
for a metric called CPU utilization over
the last two hours and I am restricting
the result set to only be the data for
instances that have a prefix called
front-end and in addition I'm the dot
align says I want to down sample the
data by five minutes using mean as my
aggregation function and the results go
into this Python object cookie one now
in the Python object we've already built
in a few utilities like line chart right
and this is just a fully interactive
line chart you know just like you start
with so it's track driver we've built
yet another utility called heat map
again the same data rendered in a
different way sometimes heat maps are
really useful in understanding aggregate
effects especially when your very large
clusters line charts tend to get very
very crowded but heat maps are just the
perfect thing you know discrepancies and
just pop out at you this is a tiny
project so you're not seeing as many
instances on the y-axis here but this is
not about built-in utilities that Google
provides it's about giving you access to
the raw data and this is where the fun
really begins with the same object q1
you can get the data as a pan
those data frame again if you recall
from the keynote Google Cloud data lab
is built-in support for pandas pandas is
a widely used open-source statistical
analysis package it's got a very rich
ecosystem of visualizations of other
libraries like scikit-learn that you can
do statistical machine learning on that
data you can really play with that data
in just a super cool awesome way with
pandas what we've shown here is I just
pull that data out as a data frame this
is a pandas object so this is a pandas
utility that says just show the first
five rows of the data frame and you can
see the data right there you got the
metric data first column are timestamps
you can see there's a hierarchy of
column headers that happen that
naturally tell you what the levels of
the hierarchy are you've got a project
zone group etc and then you can do lots
of cool things in the data frame now I
don't have the time to get into all the
different things you can do but I just
want to give you a flavor of the kind of
data that you can manipulate over here
I'm just applying a filter which takes a
regular expression on all the column
headers and it just finds anything that
math any column that matches Europe West
one B and it's just showing me the data
for that I can aggregate data by project
ID and zone by just giving the different
levels by using mean as my aggregation
function and then doing a group by and
I'm just showing the first five rows of
that data frame and so on and so forth
so before I wind up you know when we
were doing the demo at the keynote right
in the middle of the demo Dan we're
standing over the corner and he toggled
the load so that the load shifted from
AWS resources to GCP resources and just
out of curiosity I decided to hack this
up before I got here to see whether we
can actually see the Apache request
count metric for the last two hours and
I'm doing a down sampling by five
minutes if I can actually see that load
shift as a heat map so I have no idea
what I'm
I'm gonna see but let's let's check it
out
oh I just caught the load shift right
right here I could have widened the
hours to three and you would have seen
this but what this is showing is the top
two instances apparently were not
involved in the load toggling I think
they were backup instances and but then
you see earlier in the time there was a
shift from load from AWS resources to
the GCP resources okay so to recap what
we've shown you here is a way to
directly tap into the underlying data in
stock driver with an ad hoc interface in
the situation where the super-awesome
stock driver interface is not adequate
with that let me hand the control back
to them thank you very much for us
alright so to wrap it up first of all we
want to thank you for your time it was a
pleasure to tell you about the new
Google stack driver we hit on a few key
themes so the first thing I'll recap is
we try to make it really easy for you to
get the visibility that you need whether
it's at the cloud platform layer the
system layer or the application layer
right next we talked about integrations
you know be it the monitoring
integration with our agents or our
logging agent flew in D or third-party
notification tools like page of duty and
slack and campfire and HipChat and also
these new and exciting integrations with
other tools within the Google cloud
platform the bigquery logging
integration was law was launched last
year - great applause many of you are
using it actively the data lab
integration will be available for you
very shortly and we're really excited
about that on the time series front we
talked about insights now what we think
about and sort of obsess over is how can
we support an operator or a developer on
call going from that page of duty alert
or that SMS to go all the way through
whatever signals they need to get
through to get to root cause we show the
initial stages of that in terms of
integrating monitoring and logging you
could also see integration between
monitoring and tracing and error
reporting and so we intend to go further
and further
in terms of bringing these tools and
capabilities together and then finally
we talked about cloud platform and how
we embrace Google cloud AWS and we
intend to support additional platforms
as you tell us that you want us to and
so thank you very much for your time you
can try Google stackdriver free in beta
right now and if you have any questions
we'll be at the infrastructure and
operations booth out in the floor thank
you
you